ah again i've been working double shifts
for three weeks man said show me what
animals are where and the route get on
or don't it doesn't it doesn't matter to
me sir it really
it really actually doesn't matter if you
get on the car or not
[Music]
what's good guys what's good girls we're
back with the bloody vengeance hey come
on come on
uh it's monday guys sunday guys
how's my little juice all right
um and we're here to vibe guys this is
episode hundred and ninety nine now
how close 99 guys close to that 200.
200
fears just broke his microphone
oh is it actually broke no no no no no
no no no oh
boy cool man all right sorry about that
guys all good
um
so yeah episode 200 is around the corner
literally two dubs round the bend yeah
that's going to be on thursday guys
episode 200 is going to be on thursday
it's a patreon episode
episode you guys we already know where
this is going yeah you know where this
is going if you've been here for a while
you've been with us a while you know
what to do guys if you want to catch the
special edition episode of episode 200
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs and wait for
thursday because it's going to blow up
over there okay guys
we've got a massive community over there
everyone's chirps and everyone's having
a good time everyone's vibing um 50 of
the content is over there guys and
you've got best part of three years of
content to catch up on over there as
well guys so
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
it's gonna cost you three pound a month
10p a day run the p guys
join the cult get real get serious yeah
mom about these shits and gigs okay um
guys as always if you are watching us on
youtube please like the video if you
liked the video check the thing in the
comments as always and make sure you
ring the notification bell as well and
subscribe to the channel
for
and
finally if you are listening to your
usher-esque soulful r b voices on
spotify apple podcast google podcast
amazon music wherever you listen to your
podcast please
subscribe to us leave us a nice review
and tell a friend to tell a friend so we
can spread the holy
works spread the laughs and uh get this
coal up and running guys white robes and
uses are the uniforms you know the word
you know what it is uh and without
any
further ado
over to my friend compadre
slippy throat cause
fire lord fuegs for the fun fact of the
day let's get into it i'm excited
episode 199 please
give me some energy and [ __ ] hit me
with a fun fact bro let's go let's
[ __ ] go i'm ready now right have you
ever heard of the reverse zoo
no so they're right wait what
i just called you reverse zoo yeah so
animals outside
people inside
so there's a reverse zoo in china where
the visitors are locked in a cage and
live there the visitors are locked in a
cage on arrival and the animals just
roam free
and this is a picture
oh
wow hell no bro yeah
hell
[ __ ] no
because
i already know something's going to go
wrong if imagine i'm one of the drivers
that day and i've just had a long ass
day i've had a [ __ ] day i've probably
had arguing with my missus at home i've
not paid the rent shit's hitting the fan
and i'm just there like driving driving
driving
you know this this zoo there's animals
everywhere animals everywhere
i'm just not in the [ __ ] mood i
forget to lock the gate
i forget i do one one little mess up i
don't tick off all the things and i
don't need my safety checklist the
safety check can't be due diligence it's
my third tour
tick sign tick scientific scientix i
just you know blindly fam i forgot to do
one lot
i'm driving all i hear is screams
he's in
one of them's in
fam
i will speed off
i would speed off and whoever whoever
falls out falls out rags i'm as long as
i'm safe in the front
bro mistakes happen that
that's a lawsuit waiting to happen
that them kind of things are a lawsuit
i mean it looks intense i don't really
see the added benefit
but it's basic it's it's basically a
safari yeah it literally is a more
intense safari but like
less fun because you're actually in a
cage oh yeah you can't even see through
there probably no it's not you've got
little tiny holes to peek through like
it looks dead i'm not gonna lie
i just don't understand how
okay
because i'm deep in it now they've taken
a picture when they're in the zoo right
and the animals are around their boat
where obviously where they start if they
start outside a zoo they get in blah
blah blah so how do they stop the
animals leaving the zoo
when they're trying to
come out of the van where do they park
this van
it's probably just like a a gay open
shutting in it yep big man if it's a
gate surely animals can pass through
like if if i'm a lion and i'm starving i
see 17 men in a van oh i'm following
that van big man
oh yeah right there's probably a couple
i would assume there's a couple of
security dons of like electric sticks
and tranquilizer guns yeah yeah just
open the gate let the car through a
couple managers wait
close the gate it seems pointless to me
i can never be in that kind of setting i
don't need a lion like literally like up
on on the thing like that no no that'll
give me a panic attack that'll give me a
[ __ ] panic attack i don't know what
if you pop a tire who's coming to change
it
oh that scared me don't say that yeah if
you pop a tire who's coming to change
the tire oh i'm riding on that flat oh
yeah of course that alloy yeah damaged
because i'm i'm peeling off yeah peeling
off to the exit
the whole thing's stupid yes i don't
know why people play games with these
animals i i really yeah really humans
love to play games with animals they
love to push their boundaries until one
of them gets yammed of course and
they'll probably reopen in the next four
months we apologize we've we've added
some safety done some investigation
and there were a couple like
leaking holes yeah yeah yeah that we
found out that on that day the guy
didn't sign off all the checklists yeah
drunk on shift he didn't lock the gate
that guy is not with us he's no longer
with us the company's safe you're safe
we are reopened big man this is for i
would never go on that test i don't
think i'm
i don't see
why i would ever want to go in safari
i wouldn't mind doing a safari purely
because i think that's one of the
um
what's the word i'm looking for
i don't know i just see something cool
that i'd want to do if i'm visiting like
south africa for example like i don't
know whatever tanzania where these these
nice countries that they do um safari is
in
it's just something i'd like to do just
to take it off a list
but then again i think you wouldn't do
that because safari is like an open g i
know i know but it's
i wouldn't
i'd have to ask my man show me the map
of where we're going like show me what
animals are in which sections fam yeah
it's the wild
everyone's everywhere doing what they
want
what animals are you shocked
i've been working double shifts for
three weeks man said show me what
animals are where and the root get on or
don't it doesn't it doesn't matter to me
sir it really
really actually doesn't matter if you
get on the car or not the thing is i'd
want to i'd want to get on by the same
time i don't want to be there i'm not
i'm not doing it i'd want to see it
because i'll be vexed if let's say i'm
i'm the one just chilling carrying all
your man's bags wait if you minutes come
back
and you go around
normal nice safari road trip and you man
take bag of pictures is a fantastic
experience
and i'm just like yeah i'm just never
gonna go
i would i would hold the bags rags you
man could come back with all the
pictures
i don't care i literally don't care like
it
yeah it's just dangerous animals doing
dangerous animals [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
like where in their territory yeah fam
like the the
i think that's the main reason the only
pictures you could show me that would be
worth showing me
are the pictures that would convince me
why i shouldn't have gone yeah jeremy
death death is the only thing you could
show me that i would have been like oh
yeah i saw that well i'm obviously still
glad i didn't go
because that's dangerous
[Music]
that's foolish yeah i've seen i've seen
videos boy
like
either lions or um tigers or whatever
peeling towards the van or the the 4x4
or the suv whatever it is
absolutely running towards it no
and it's like [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me like that's
yeah it's crazy
did we ever i can't know if we were shot
on here or not did you ever see that
video the light the tiger these men in
india were just on a car yeah the tiger
just peels out of the forest and just
starts going for them yeah yeah yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] jumps take some man's
arm yeah bro it takes a man's arm i'm
sure yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] yeah
bro i've seen that one it's just that
yeah yeah i don't see the point the same
with like shark [ __ ] just leave it all
right in the cage
just leave it bruh
just leave it yeah that's that's
nonsense that's i can't even breathe
that's nonsense no ma'am yeah i don't
get like
adrenaline stuff from that the way i
think about like skydiving the way i'd
feel when i land
wow what an experience like i was
[ __ ] flying like that was insane
flying i was literally flying
flying but like getting in a cage with a
shark coming at the bus yeah i'm not i'm
not gonna come out of the cage like wow
i'm gonna come out shaking here like
what the [ __ ]
never put me in there again
he was coming for man you man didn't
even say that was a possibility you said
they were they don't care about us oh no
he was sending for the bars yeah dead
all of that yeah what's the point that
all of them yeah i don't need and it
will just convince me why i shouldn't
ever be in the ocean oh facts
i shouldn't ever be in the ocean the
ocean is is one place
mandem just don't need to go to it's
it's their territory if we don't belong
leave it alone yeah because they have no
regards for us they will yammer to spit
us out
all right leave us alone
and i'm just there with no art just
bleeding out
there's yeah there's just no excuse
there is no excuse anyway speaking of
killers
wow
speaking of killers um
i'm about a week behind yeah
but
i need to talk to you about ufc 276.
okay i haven't done a ufc like breakdown
in a while or a boxing breakdown yeah oh
this card was good okay this card was
good right when was this
this was
last last weekend okay um but my boy
style bender was fighting right oh i saw
he got tums no oh i saw a picture of him
getting tumped
he definitely didn't
maybe i think of something else i don't
know okay right so anyway
this is why the card is interesting
right okay so on the card yeah sean
o'malley versus some guy that was a dead
fight shauna maddie's like this up and
coming star who thinks he's like the
dog's bollocks hasn't really been tested
but the way his fights get given to him
make it
he's like very instagram popular and
stuff like that so make him obvious that
they're like trying to build him up to
be like in his division like a serious
guy he is a very talented guy but like
it's whatever um so
but right so
the undercard that we had
right so
there's a brazilian
fighter called pereira right okay
he was fighting a guy called sean
strickland okay right so this is this is
where it gets interesting right yeah so
pereira yeah
is a former kickboxer who's recently
come over to ufc yeah
stahlbender yeah is also a former
kickboxer who obviously years ago came
over to the ufc yeah
pereira
is one of if not the only person to
absolutely annihilate starbender in
kickboxing okay who has now recently
joined the same weight class in the same
federation yeah in mma
okay and he's been
tumping man up okay in the lower these
lower levels so pereira's had like five
fights up into this point or maybe six i
think he's got one loss
uh which may not have that could have
been a different mma it may not have
even been ufc i didn't say i haven't
seen him lose in the ufc but anyway he's
had a couple fights in the ufc's top man
up and they've kind of you can tell
they're trying to fast track him
to the championship fight with him
number one contender type thing yeah bro
so usually they build mine up for ages
he's only had a few fights and they pair
him up with sean strickland which i
think at the time he was ranked number
four in their division okay so he's a
big boy sean strickland's a big boy yeah
they sent pereira in there
fam
two minutes into the first round
rock strickland's jaw really left i
think it was a left hook pop
set his lights went out
two minutes into the first round yeah
clotted him yeah out
now everyone was like
send him to izzy now send him to
starboard and now he's ready we need to
see this yeah so this is the interesting
thing so
and then okay cool so that fight locked
in first round pereira's done his thing
he's solidified he's going to move on to
the next one is he's not definitely not
going to fight him for a while because
so like starboard is obviously the
champion he gets he doesn't get to
decide but you can't force him to fight
anyone
he has to like obviously defend his
title a certain amount
but at least probably like once a year
they will never make him do it more than
once a year okay so it would be more
than that to be fair
nah i don't really think so what's this
continue with the story and second
what's the season like in ufc how does
it work season is it is it does it every
weekend it's on but so there's no season
so it doesn't stop and then restart
again at a specific point no ah okay
fight it's fight okay
um they have like more popular ones like
i think july is typically that might
have been the july one to be fair um
typically july they have like big cards
okay and big fights and stuff like that
but like yeah it's on all year round all
year round um
so pereira has now moved on to the next
level to fight star bender which is
juicy and he's he's he's thumping man up
sorry and that's due to happen soon
it won't be soon but like it's one of
the next maybe next if he the only way
it's going to happen soon is if
izzy doesn't fight now for like another
year
and in that time pereira takes loads of
fights
and tops every man up and makes himself
undeniable so that star bender has no
choice because the thing with being the
champion you kind of get to cherry pick
your fights yeah you can't make it
obvious that you're dodging someone yeah
okay you have to fight the top guys the
top guy the main number one yeah yeah
you've got like kind of like the top
three one two and three contenders kind
of that you
when they've paid their dues they are
due a title shot yeah and dana will tell
you these this homeboy is jew like
you're fighting him you're fighting
you've got no choice yeah you're
fighting him you're fighting him so but
like they can't force you if he's like
number 12 like ranked 12th or whatever
yeah and he's trying to get a
championship fight and because he's got
like a million instagram followers that
might have telling you you have to find
a sharp he hasn't paid his juice like
i'm not fighting him so you have a
little bit leeway but not much okay
so i reckon it could be within the next
year if pereira starts just wiping
people out
to work his way up to izzy he can but it
depends how he sees his own career maybe
he might want to build up slowly the way
same way is he upset i think izzy was
fighting i think in his first year he
had like three or four fights okay in
the ufc so he made his way to champion
like quick but he had a lot of fights
um
next fight
bro
so it might not been the last time maybe
the time before that that i did a ufc
breakdown
there was alexander volkanovsky versus
brian ortega okay
and i told you it was a
oh yeah yeah we're going back round and
round blood blood blood yeah
i remember and volkanovsky
dropped brian ortega
and then tried to capitalize and then
brian will take a quarter triangle yeah
yeah yeah
i remember that was a fight
oh my god yeah that's one of the best
fights i've seen in the ufc oh gang [ __ ]
yeah so anyway
brian ortega uh it might have been a
couple it was a few years ago now got
tumped up
by a guy called max holloway max
holloway is like the uncrowned boxing
king of the ufc he likes to call himself
the best boxer in the ufc and there's
been a couple of times he actually has
proved he's put paws on man in there
before yeah
one of his last few fights maybe last
year i think it was he topped up a guy
who the guy max was fighting was saying
that he's the best boxer in the ufc and
master was like swear so when they were
fighting max was giving them the
combinations
from he gave him like a bat bat bap the
guy swang he ducked behind it smashed
him again
looked at homeboy's coach and was like
who's the best boxer
who's the best [ __ ] boxer whack whack
he taunt i can't remember who he was
fighting tap the lights out with this
guy that's embarrassing bro
you can't come back from that so yeah a
couple years ago max holloway also
topped up brian ortega okay we had the
insane fight with uh volkanovsky yeah so
now it's volkanovsky versus max holloway
bro
we're expecting arm's house oh it's not
it's due to happen this happened oh it's
happened it happened okay before the
fight we're responsible okay okay okay
because max holloway has been talking
this is the their third fight okay max
has lost all uh twice okay and he came
in like bro i'm [ __ ] ready for it i'm
ready for it bro
alex
alexander volkanovsky
is
a trained assassin
he's short of [ __ ] i need to see what
his brother looks like oh he's a trained
assassin
i need to see
he he he made max look like an amateur
oh really bro he made max look like an
amateur out there and not actually no he
didn't make he actually tell a lie he
didn't actually make alex um max look
like an amateur
he just
he how do i explain it
he's short five six
yeah
max followers okay i'm just saying i'm
checking these people out and saying
them yeah he
made
max look like he's playing the wrong
sport
no
he made like
how do i explain it
imagine
okay imagine you remember that time
where there was rumors where dwayne
chambers was trying to uh
be like a nfl player
yeah so
it's like him going to the nfl being
like i'm fast as [ __ ]
like i can do this
and then actual nfl stars like just
educating them on the spot like you're
in the wrong place yeah you're in the
wrong sport you're in the wrong spot
this is how it's done yeah like that's
how like volk made max holloway look
like oh you can throw a couple punches
and kicks us that's cute
this is this is a man's sport this is a
blood spot yeah yeah coming for blood
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're on some
sparring yeah i'm trying to take lives
i'm trying to take lives and teeth yeah
yeah
volkl's moving like he's in the heart of
ukraine oh wow defending the country
that's how he was moving yeah yeah he
ended up
oh my god so it actually went to a
decision max didn't get knocked out max
is a chin of gods he doesn't get rocked
like that
volk was giving him
he didn't even take
the okay the special thing about
alexander volkonovsky is strong as [ __ ]
yeah
i think he's a former rugby player
actually he is i i i
came up as well um
he is a very talented wrestler okay so
max holloway is obviously an extreme
talented boxer
and striker volck is an extremely
talented wrestler
so that's always something that when
you're a striker you have to be careful
people who are talented wrestlers okay
you just have to be when you say striker
people that just go for it strike like
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah so striker yeah
strike it in mma striker means hit okay
um so people who are good at hitting
punching and kicking yeah that's people
are good at grappling wrestling okay
i'm with you
yeah yeah fam so you'd be thinking when
you're up against volk you're thinking
right i've got i've got striking down
he's gonna try and take me down i need
to be ready to defend it and break his
nose
bro
vodka didn't try no wrestling hmm he
squared up knuckle to knuckle okay
knuckle to knuckle
and just gave him pat he was rapid he
was giving him back
back
mack's face was gushing with blood and
vonk is telling him bro you're too slow
he was telling back to his face bro
you're too slow
you're too slow saying it he was saying
it no he was saying it to his face
bro you're in the wrong ring bro you're
too slow
connecting everything
who had he connected everything every
round
max max didn't do anything that fight he
was trying his best as well oh he was
actually trying his best
and he couldn't land anything on him
vonk just had him up
and then like i honest to god if i was
max holloway because he's been in the
game a few years now i would retire if i
was him
oh
after that fight
you need to know you're never gonna be
champion facts facts that's one that's
one of those fights it's like oh there's
just levels to this and i'm never
ever gonna be better than him and that's
just an reality yeah that's reality damn
bro it's reality i'm never going to be
better than that and it's not like he
used his um
grappling and he took his strengths
against my strengths and i'm not good
enough to defend his strengths no no no
no level play what i do best yeah that
he's not even his strength
pumped the lights out of me
oh yeah
i need to retire yeah yeah there's
nothing left for me here yeah that's
just fam that's like a footballer
jumping into nbn absolutely draining
threes in matches training threes
bro nah that's literally is literally
like
like yeah it's literally like a [ __ ]
high jumper deciding they want to play
nba
and they can just dunk they can just
jump for [ __ ] yeah
and then everyone's like yeah but he
can't dribble he can't shoot yeah and
then he gets in there he can dribble he
can shoot and he can dunk better than
all of you all and you're like oh ra
maybe he isn't yeah he's just that guy
i can't compete with that yeah because
his like his strength is already way
better and he's not even using his
strength he's classing me on my strength
this is the thing that i tell the crowd
i'm the best in the ufc at this one
thing and he just took me toe to toe and
i couldn't even land a punch on him and
my face won't stop bleeding
it was a fight you need to tell i think
going forward if there are banging
fights or banging lineups let me know
beforehand alright i'll watch it yeah
i'll tell you what i'll try and keep you
i'll tell you what moving forward if i
can keep an eye on it i don't want to
make commitments i can't stick to it
yeah
but if i can keep an eye on the cards
the week before yeah or the week of or
whatever i will
let everyone know the card that's coming
up and why i think it's an interesting
card and why i think it'd be good fights
and stuff like that cool and then we can
recap after but yeah oh my god because
obviously i i don't watch ufc but i've
seen ufc obviously but i just don't know
the play i don't know the fighters i
don't know the game yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that much that's the thing i don't
i don't watch all of ufc if there's a
good card with people that i know about
i'll get into it okay and you said you
said it's every week oh most weeks [ __ ]
it's almost weeks but yeah to find a
card like this is rare okay this is rare
bro there's fighters on this card okay
okay and then the the next one was
obviously style bender versus a guy
called cannoneer right
this is interesting right
so people are getting fed up with
starbender at the minute why but is it
it's a
it's like uh
it's almost like a challenge
you can't get annoyed at him because
it's almost like a challenge right so
people as fans are getting annoyed with
him so when basically when star bender
was coming up he's basically doing a
basically what stanford is doing at the
minute is what floyd mayweather did so
employment with his first night boxing
he was just taking souls from people
yeah
he came out of the olympics yeah with
his silver medal i think it was i don't
think he won't call him i want god i
think he came out of a silver came out
of the olympics this golden boy
just amateur right he had some tough
fights yeah but he was just taking the
lives out of people his exciting fighter
he was doing well and then he got older
and he got better and he got more
skilled and then he just
was the best defensive fighter in the
world yeah potentially of all time yeah
and he just wouldn't stop winning yeah
and everyone was getting vex being like
oh bro he's just like a [ __ ] like he
doesn't do anything he can't knock
people out he can't do this he can't do
that and then
his rebuttal is like okay then do
something
yeah yeah fight me and wait do something
about it
yeah i'm winning these fights bro if i'm
a [ __ ] if i'm like beat me
just beat me then fast and no one can do
it yeah to this day people can't do it
okay so that's what star ben is doing a
little bit the minute is when he was
coming up in the ranks he was taking
lives from people yeah he was very
energetic he was doing all of his
kickboxing he was learning a bit of
grappling he was just having fun with it
he was
breaking jaws he was knocking people out
he was doing the most
star bender is that us man is that
um i just saw you is that the same
person
star bender is addis on yeah
yeah uh and then it's tomorrow osman
camaro is man yeah i knew there was
two but i couldn't remember which one
yeah yeah israel yeah israel
yeah and uh kamaruzman and um
they're the two african champions and
then francis and god francis of course
this is a big big boy it's a different
weight class yeah completely different
he'll
[Music]
he would murder people yeah he's a
[ __ ] tank so yeah um
anyway yeah so starbenders what's up has
been doing for the last few fights ever
since he fought so the last time star
bender
[ __ ] someone up yeah i would say oh
okay cool cool cool right so yeah yeah
so basically
he was coming up the ranks he had really
really cool fights he had an amazing
like fight with anderson silva okay uh
which was more like a spectacle than
anything anderson's like way past his
prime and stuff like that uh and
anderson silva was like star bender's
like hero in the ufc so he got to fight
him and it was just like a showboating
fight it was more like an exhibition
match star bender beat him then he moved
on uh to fight kevin gastelum
[Music]
one of the one of the all-time ufc
fights okay well they had a war oh yeah
they had if you look at kevin gaslin
you'll never think that he would give
anyone a hard time oh really bro
that guy has heart
kevin gaston has heart like um
this is the slim bread and the slim
brother from warrior
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
like kevin gaster oh he has heart okay
him and star bender went blow for blow
both of their faces were swollen to [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then the last round style
bender famously was up against the ring
up against the the cage just panning
looked at kevin was like i'm willing to
die i'm ready to die here
he said it bro they bring it up on
camera all the time i'm ready to die
here [ __ ] it's over [ __ ] i'm ready to
die in this cage bro let's go yeah so i
think that was his first yeah that was
when he
won the title i think from kevin
gastelum did he defend or did he win it
from
uh robert whitaker i can't remember um
but then anyway yeah he saw he had a war
against kevin gastelum he had a war
against robert whittaker then he
defended his title against uh
joel romero
yo romero was the first fight where he
started to really just like not put
himself out there he this is when he
moves into money mayweather mode okay
he was pretty boy floyd yeah now he's
money waiting he's looking out for
himself yeah yeah yeah he's not getting
hurt for no reason yeah yeah yeah so
basically he just started doing this
thing where he just uses his speed and
his technique and his skill to just pick
people apart yeah he just does leg kicks
jabs a little elbow here he doesn't let
you take him down he doesn't do anything
crazy he just picks at you picks at you
picks at you doesn't try and knock you
out
there's nothing you can do about it the
crowd gets frustrated it's boring to
them yeah um and they're just making out
like he's moving like a [ __ ] but he's
winning he's winning so he's like
winning and he's coming out unscathed
it's uh what's the it's um an endurance
type yeah yeah yeah so i'm gonna pick
your part i'm gonna win and i'm going to
come out feeling fresh tomorrow yeah so
that he did that and then he had a fight
against paolo costa hola costa's wham
thu had he's wham let me kick you kill
him paulo costa's wham yeah i've
listened so he fought him palace was
talking the most [ __ ] paola acosta and
uh
and he was he was he was yeah talking
smack he's gonna do this to izzy he's
gonna do that to izzy same thing izzy
just
cracked his
femur
with leg kick off the leg kicking off
the leg kick paula couldn't even walk in
his leg after i just pulled paula uh um
it's paulo sorry paul paul lower costa
paulo
yeah um
so he beat him picked him apart oh yeah
he's one yeah then he tried to go up
a weight class he went up weight class
to see how he could get on with light
heavyweight okay he was like from midway
to light everywhere he's middleweight
now yeah yeah he had a hard time looking
all right yeah he had a hard time went
straight up against the champion oh wow
yeah yeah yeah so he worked to be the
double champ okay you want to have the
light heavyweight belt plus the
middleware belt okay uh he went out this
guy called young
uh like i can't remember he's like a
polish guy like black or wits or is
russian maybe um
he's a big guy john's big bro so
is he actually defending himself quite
well but once it got to the floor you
can't he can't compete with that he's
too heavy yeah yeah so anyway he then
went back down to his white class
defended against uh marvin vittori
same thing picked him apart yadda yadda
people are getting more vex he fought
robin robert whitaker again picked him
apart
and that was a bit more of a closer
match but because he's not doing much
and he's winning by decisions people are
like looking for reasons like oh but he
didn't win that round like it's it's all
fixed it's all this is that like he's
boring fighting like how could he be
winning these fights and then he did the
exact same thing with jared kenna the
other day picked him apart all this all
that people are vex bro people like this
guy what's he doing bro yeah like he's
moving like a [ __ ] or this like this
that but he's doing the money mayweather
ting was like beat me there beat me then
if you're gonna chat all this [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
do something the stepping ox are gonna
beat me literally do something about it
like you're vex you're just sitting here
vex right you're just chatting bro and
then you step in the cage and i do it to
you the same thing you're cussing me for
doing to him you let me do to you let me
you left me yeah yeah yeah you come in
and you let me treat you how i wanted to
treat you bro scrap me scrap me if you
if you came in to scrap come in here and
scrap me yeah because i would jab
stepping
i would just never rub my elbow around
in your nose yeah and then you you don't
know what to do for the rest of the
fight
so that's how that's how it's moving
yeah so now that's why
people are so so so intrigued by this
pereira
because he's like the known guy who has
fought
uh stylebender twice in kickboxing and
tumped the [ __ ] out of him both times
right that was years ago is he's a
different guy now he's different the
money's different yeah and his skills
are different yeah yeah yeah but
mentally that will remain oh
that will remain yeah oh do you think is
he wanting to see him knock a guy out in
two minutes yesterday he didn't want to
see it
he did not want to see it or hear it
[ __ ] he wanted to know that homeboy's
gonna have a little bit of trouble yeah
he's in here knocking people out in two
minutes [ __ ] the number four contender
yeah yeah yeah he's been in the party
five minutes yeah he's knocking out
number four in two minutes bro he's not
beat that day oh one million percent
yeah and that was before his fight he
had to focus
mentally that's long oh mentally that
will knock me for six bro because i'd
want to go out there and prove to these
men that i can do that too yeah i can
knock him out in one minute i'll be
knocking him out in 30 seconds thank you
yeah that will [ __ ] with the whole game
plan so i rate him for having the mental
fortitude to stick to his game plan yeah
even knowing that his arch nemesis just
starched a bread a couple minutes ago
[ __ ] that's annoying it's a juicy game
right and they're due to fight when who
herrera and starbender undisclosed they
may never fight ah but it's the one
that's in the that's the one they're
looking for they're building for erupted
to get in there okay
it's going to be one of those things
they won't let him
they won't let him risk
not getting a championship fight they're
going to pick his fights carefully for
him okay so that he can fight stalberg
in one day okay
i doubt it would be next year it's not
been the smart he won't fight him next
year because starboard makes [ __ ]
money okay so like the risky fights yeah
don't do it yeah it's not no worth it
yeah yeah yeah and just you got more
time to to get more skilled and do all
this and do all that so yeah minus fam
wholesome times cool wholesome times in
the ufc oh yeah juicy so yeah as you
said before um next card that you think
that's interesting let us know
beforehand
we can wrap we can watch it and then we
can we can analyze afterwards
i'm very intrigued every time you talk
about it but because i don't know who
these brothers are and because i don't
know
it's just chat but i'm trying to
visualize
everything but that's how i feel when
you uh talk about football i love the
energy that you're giving me but i don't
know what you're wrong about
you know what i mean i don't know what
you're saying bro but i love it football
right now is obviously it's um it's on
the
everyone's on a break football's ended
all the seasons ended
and it's all like the transfer window
blah blah blah and it's so frustrating
because up until not just maybe just a
few days for a whole month united hadn't
signed anyone
all of their mates have been signing
doing deals
they're in everywhere yeah yeah
liverpool have got um darwin nunes who
is a portuguese brother
um i think i can't remember who he
played for but he was banging in goals
in these leagues yeah liverpool scooped
him yeah because umani went to um by
munich manci
mancity have now got um
harland who used to play for
borussia dortmund
he's like i think he's 21 now i think
maybe two seasons ago he banged them 51
goals
something like that he was 19. he was 19
brother he was banging in goals that
season oh dear he's
a
machine james
and he can run this way this
[ __ ] can run okay he's from
where is he from
um eric harland or erling harlan where's
he from where's he from i think norway i
think he's norwegian okay i think he's
norwegian oh he's a big city signed him
he's a [ __ ] beast arsenal have signed
gabrielle jesus who came from manchester
city striker baller yeah yeah um who
else is in the ranking um
who else is there chelsea
who have chelsea you got i think chelsea
are trying to find some people and i
can't remember who they've got but
they've got rid of lukaku and they got
rid of someone else but we've only just
got um
we've only just recently signed
uh christian erickson do you know
christian eriksen is yeah so he's the
brother that had the heart yeah yeah
yeah
yeah he was currently he was at
brentford all last season or since
january and he changed the way brentford
played
changed the way brentford he's he's in a
he's an attacking midfielder like a
defensive midfielder and he
he can scan the room and pick up passes
and crosses and corners like he is a
talisman like the [ __ ] uh the
redheaded guy from kurukona basket
the point guard yes yes bro yes so he's
a talisman all right so i'm happy we
have him and we've got another guy i
think his name is uh malaysia a camera
where he's from is a defender i'm gonna
get in
hopefully
um another guy called martinez who's
also a defender from argentina i believe
um but yeah
we've done we've only started to do a
few deals in the last week whereas
everyone else has just been slamming all
these big names all these big big names
that we should have at least had a
running it especially um
[Music]
nunes um darwin nunes i think his name i
think his fair name is um darwin but
he's definitely nunes he was um
yeah in the champions league last season
he was banging in goals
banging in goals so i'm saying i am
looking forward to this season even
though i know united aren't going to do
the best yeah which is very frustrating
but i'm just looking forward to football
in general okay because i uh fam without
it i'm just like
yeah without it i'm just like i don't
want to do myself sometimes and i'm so
[ __ ] i'm so excited for the world cup
it's in
november because it's in qatar because
of the sun and stuff the way the sun is
they had to do it in our winter time
which is or their winter time which is
november um so i don't know how the
season's going to work because the world
cup should have started last month
normal normally but because it's
happening in november i don't know how
they're going to break up hours our
regular season because the season starts
from
august till may so they're going to have
to
give up a whole month for the world cup
yeah and then do it from august until
june until june but then then but then
the transfer window and like the summer
stuff is all shortened so i just don't
know how the next season is going to
work yeah maybe just not doing qatar in
it maybe we just don't do it there next
time
yeah i'm very much looking forward to
the world cup i heard that they've
they've got rules over there in qatar
yeah in terms of just in general yeah in
terms of like for the world cup like
have you seen that the announcement they
made like maybe a half batch there no
[ __ ] my g
like because obviously they're they're a
muslim country yeah of course of course
the man said
any like if you if you get caught having
a one night stand
it's pen
what the players anyone one anyone
that's coming into qatar for the world
cup oh wow because the man that lived
here already know what
anyone
coming in yeah do not [ __ ] anyone that's
not your wife that's what they said
anyone i don't care if you're a
footballer if you're a manager if you're
an owner i don't care who you are bro
don't touch any [ __ ] that hasn't got
your name on it oh wow otherwise it's a
painting oh wow oh there are cup i know
with at least a hundred england man or
go in jail oh
plus yeah because it says they also
no um
public uh intoxication like don't be on
road drunk yeah
don't know drunk [ __ ] anyone thousands
of england fighters coming back
they're not coming back they're not
coming back oh and if you get caught uh
smuggling in cocaine oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah center yeah yeah i heard about
that one i heard about that one yeah
they're not [ __ ] about
and no not me and drunk the englishman
ain't gonna know what to do out there
they won't be charging anymore right we
sat there watching a game like this
don't be drunk and don't [ __ ] anything
yeah that's um yeah it's gonna be okay
johnny's can't live like that yeah
that's going to be very very very
interesting a lot of men won't make it
back oh family a lot of english fans
weren't making better they're thinking
but i don't understand like
so is football cancelled yeah
all i heard was no drinking so so the
world cups came out the world is done
there yeah yeah no drinking and no [ __ ]
yeah yeah woke up has to be that's not
[ __ ]
that's not why i was brought up yeah i
was that's i was brought up in a
football house yeah we're hooligans yeah
why did you mean no drink no [ __ ]
that's not making any sense that's what
is the world cup cancer that's jokes um
but anyway moving on i've got uh and am
i the [ __ ] okay all right guys we're
gonna take a very very very quick break
to
keep the lights on and
spread some love to our guys and gals
over at manscape guys so summer is
coming the sun is shining shirts are off
and your balls are smooth brother
smooth
big man you heard it right your friends
at manscaped are here to make sure your
beach balls
are as smooth as a
floridian sand my g wow for those of you
who haven't gone to florida the sand is
soft soft wow soft soft brown just like
floridian sand that miami yeah
come on man
in summer you want to kill some cold
beers and barbecues not kill the vibe
with pubes peeking out of your swimming
trunks
facts that's why manscaped has their
performance package 4.0 to keep the
party in your pants looking crisp and
refreshing all summer long guys dive
head first into summer by joining the 4
million men your boys included who trust
manscape to get ready for hot guy summer
my guys
go over to moundscape.com and for 20 off
and free shipping use the code sng
sierra november golf
one more time from the top manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping go over
there and use code sng sierra november
golf and guys feel lavish with us all
right let's get back to the episode
fam
question hold on
on condom boxes right have you ever
noticed the fit size on there
sorry what do you mean by fit
so durex have this thing right where
they've got fit sizes on the actual
condoms they've got close fit regular
fit and wide fit obviously on a girth
thing which i never knew about
i've never seen this thing in my life a
girth team yeah bro fam listen
when i was like 17 18 19 um
when i was just getting into this this
pleasure game yeah
yeah yeah yeah when i was getting into
this skin on skin game
i um i was having trouble with condoms
bro like what i'm saying like i think
i've told you before like the things
just weren't fitting none of them were i
couldn't get them on bro and i was just
like oh ra like this is not working yeah
so i remember i went shop one day and i
was just looking for something else and
i saw a packet it literally just said xl
yeah i was like
that's me that's
that's the product i've been looking for
i don't know i haven't found it earlier
snagged a box yeah went with my girl
that evening
and bro whipped it out same thing could
not get it on little i don't know these
men are talking exhale long
i needed a girlfriend
so it was a lengthening not a girl these
men are talking long not wide okay and
i'm thinking raw okay in my head i'm
just like okay well that's a wrap then
isn't it yeah that's just a wrap nothing
else
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll just never have
sex again and that's just the way i'm
gonna live my life yeah van little did
not know
daddy needed that that widened slide is
that what you're telling me doc
is that what you're telling me fam
i've been in similar situations like you
know back in back when you're a teenager
i'll do my thing try to strap up in that
again
type bro i was thinking what kind of
blood circulation loss is this
do you know what i mean
like this doesn't feel right to me yeah
yeah this just doesn't feel right to me
like it wasn't pleasurable whatsoever
until i found these bad boys
fam start once you find the right fit
don't
say things that you can't take once you
find the right fit james the pleasure is
up up up swear up up up
you're gonna love it
stop yeah bro it's just now you're
guessing it's juicy you're gay
today
bro it's actually mad because mandem
just don't talk about this stuff nobody
talks about it we just don't talk about
it bro and like
i'm embarrassed to say like till now i
didn't know this was the thing till now
i'm a grown man through her bro it's
wild i'm a grown-ass man i didn't know
that was it till now that's actually
that's crazy bro there you go yeah
everyone needs to know about it man bro
yeah yeah we need to get the word out
still but um yeah man i'm glad to hear
it and
oh you know how i like my condoms bro
durable and flexible oh on a durex thing
yeah
direct supporting
all right bet so this is
it's not normally [ __ ] guys basically
in a i've got a dilemma i should say
okay right
so
this guy's sent us in he said gents i
need your opinion stroke advice okay
what would you do in this scenario so my
said i'm 28 and i've been single for
nearly three years
and always been very cutthroat when it
comes to dating
i would call it a day over something so
minor and be extremely picky
so i've been seeing this girl for around
a month all going smooth
she is bang on my type blonde blue eyes
petite
i'm not the biggest guy so i like my
girls small
we get on like a house on fire but when
it comes to sex i mean it's [ __ ] i
said i mean it's [ __ ] basic
two positions max and she's not a big
fan of foreplay
oh yeah whereas i've been crazy in the
bedroom with previous partners
yet with basic sex i don't get pnc at
all i would happily lay there with her
for a while
instead of just thinking about when i'm
going home basically i'm asking what
would you do in this scenario continue
to
continue and see where it goes or just
cut it off and dip
uh times are getting on i should
continue being mad uh should i continue
being mad fussy when it comes to these
girls so basically what he's saying is
is
he's found a girl that he really really
likes but the sex is boring
and basic by his standards by his
standards
but
once he's nutted
he likes his girl so much he's on a
cuddling team yeah yeah he loves that
yeah he loves her yeah he basically
loves her yeah um i said i don't want to
dip i just want to stay and i just want
to stay and talk i don't care about the
[ __ ] sex yeah
literally you know laying on your chest
yeah he loves her yeah yeah when you
ain't got pnc that's love yeah that's
definitely love yeah
yeah
yeah
that's cool yeah um just say that
but yeah um he's saying yeah
the sex is dead but
it doesn't it bothers him but
everything else is spot on from before
the sex to after the sex everything
around the sex is amazing
but the the beat itself is dead the beat
itself is dead and she said he said
she's not into foreplay yeah she's not
sucking at all i was gonna say giving or
receiving she probably doesn't care that
much about receiving either yeah
just bear polite
what should he do
if i was in his shoes i would
stay
i mean that goes without saying
no i'm joking um but what i would
actually do is i would
try my hardest to not necessarily
convince her but
ex make her explore more
ideas about foreplay like i want to
understand why you're not really into
foreplay i'd want to know like
is it because of the fact that you don't
like sucking dick is it because you just
wanna is it because you don't really
like the sexual act in general because
two positions i'm assuming it's
missionary and i'm assuming it's um
maybe doggy or even cowgirl dog girl
cowgirl definitely it's probably a
cowgirl she probably doesn't want to get
banged from the back she's she's vanilla
yeah so it's probably
vanilla it's probably missionary and
it's probably not even reverse regular
yeah i don't even like reverse i hate
reverse brothers
stop ladies stop reverse cowgirling no
one likes it none of us like it it does
not say anything
the thing is we do i'm like yeah but she
thinks she's going she thinks she's
doing them right so she's close yeah
yeah
if you're gonna do reverse don't lean
forward on it it hurts like crazy bro it
hurts so much yes oh my days that's
something we never tell you ladies
but yeah reverse cargo is basically
trash
um but yeah back to what we were saying
i would
i'd probably sit her down if you if
they're that comfortable if i'm that
comfortable with her and vice versa i'd
set her down and watch porn with her and
be like yo we're missing out
we are missing it because it's a waiting
it's not youtube or a music yeah
yeah we're missing out babe i love you
i'm not going anywhere yeah i'm trying
to do up our sex life and
i love everything about you outside the
sex but
i can't
just be having this kind of sex and i
know
there's more to you you know
yeah i would um
i would definitely
i would ask her like because everyone
must have something
something that they're into yeah of
course regardless say like this is a
judgement-free zone zone
tell me what's the wildest [ __ ] you want
to do so tell me what you like yeah tell
me tell me what you like because i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it
no
more no regrets i'm gonna do it you
wanna piss on me do you want me to piss
on you though what is it talk to me yeah
because like
yeah they're satin in there tell me what
it is in your deepest darkest secret
like what is the nastiest [ __ ] that you
think [ __ ] i think that would turn me on
but it's something you'd never expect to
tell anyone you just thought it's weird
and you want to leave it yeah yeah yeah
what is it just tell me and we can
patent it facts and once you've broken
that yeah then you can just start
working in awesome yeah yeah yeah yeah
just get comfortable enough to say it
get drunk and just be like look man what
is it anything this is mine this this
not into floor plating is that's mad
yeah it's she's definitely not sucking
dick of course definitely not sucking
dick which
which would be so frustrating because
how can you
because regardless of what she says
there will be a guy that she sees that
she'll want to 100 there's a guy that
she would suck the skin off the absolute
goblin chris hemsworth she will suck
this skin off so you just don't know
don't want to suck my dick is what
you're saying so just tell me the truth
don't be like i'm not into foreplay so
you know it's it's it's tough man yeah
did you
did you see that that um you know that
um make the stallion video the other day
oh you definitely saw it because we put
it in the chat so i'm the homeboy
i need to watch that video again this is
what
this is what we need from life the old
redder the old brother oh yeah i said i
will suck what do you say suck that ass
like a [ __ ] neck neck bone
i'll suck that ass like a [ __ ] neck
is it is that the same brother that said
if if mega stallions are bredda i'll
clap his cheeks too oh right i didn't
yeah there was this there was another
old guy that said something similar i
don't know if it's maybe the stallion
was a bro i'll clap his cheeks as well
yeah break he said bring the bring your
cheeks here satin like that wow
where is this breath um
it's on our chat no no it's actually not
no oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's
jiggly
their arse is shaking bro
it doesn't make sense brother oh it's
god she is the definition of a juggle
back oh
fam i'd [ __ ] collapse
i'd make selling couldn't let me beat
and talk the kind of [ __ ] that she talks
because i'll be left feeling like a
crippled little boy
afterwards where i'll just be left like
i know you're not satisfied yeah yeah
yes no you're not
she was like you're done yeah get her
stuff and just walk up willy nilly a
little [ __ ] naruto backpack
get out the door willy nilly boy
oh yeah she that's a woman that's fan
that's a woman
she talks the most she does [ __ ] and her
ass is shaking
it's just not on
it's just not on i wouldn't be able it's
so
infuriating yeah to know that there's so
many levels that they're like
there's actually women i've seen in real
life that i'm like i couldn't i couldn't
manage yeah i couldn't do anything about
it yeah i couldn't do any like i can't
remember name but when we were at um
harry pinero's ting
the the tall black chick do you remember
harry potter's um birthday
remember she had curves on her she was
wearing all white like an all-white
two-piece i don't remember ah i i don't
remember i used to follow on instagram i
don't follow her anymore
but she's got a
body on her i swear body on it maybe i
do remember five eleven six four maybe i
do remember
yeah yeah there's women i've seen in my
life and i'm just like
fam it's just embarrassing if you let me
bang you it's embarrassing bro because i
don't think i can handle it yeah yeah
because you're not going to be you're
going to want more than this yeah it has
to be a threesome thing for you to even
have a
a smidge of satisfaction yeah yeah yeah
like you need the breads that i see on
pornhub yeah that i'm like
no
don't do it
then blacks guys you're just like oh no
nobody don't mind that they don't even
get it half in they're just jabbing yeah
yeah
yeah you need that
yeah i'm not no don't do it
but yeah bro oh [ __ ] oh meg sally would
i just die after bro i'll just die
afterwards she could never sit on my
face
of course not
of course not association just before
actually just before because this ties
on i've got a trash news
before we do your one it's disgraceful
you would have definitely seen it it's
been going around for a few weeks now
and so many people have sent it to me
it's this hoe
this hoe have you seen this [ __ ] oh
yeah of course i have yeah yeah all
right this chick so
once my boyfriend was asleep so i wanted
to go [ __ ] my ex real quick so i drove
down to the gas station let him cream
pie me and then i came home to sneak
into bed my boyfriend woke up and then
wanted to [ __ ] me and he started eating
me out and told me how good my [ __ ]
tasted that laugh
it's a salsa dance all over again
it's a salsa dance all over that's a 15
month expenses thing renting
that bro she said she wanted to go [ __ ]
her ex so she drove to the gas station
and he creampied me
at the gas station
bro i wanted to go [ __ ] my ex real quick
so i drove in i drove to the gas station
let him [ __ ] me
my boyfriend woke up
ate my palm
and just said how good it tastes while
he's eating next mazda army and i'm not
saying anything
boyfriend she said
boyfriend family what did he do to
deserve this nothing she was just horny
he didn't do a thing yeah he didn't do a
thing to her she's a porn star though so
that's the thing
so what
i wanted to go [ __ ] my ex real quick i
poured up to the gas station james
that doesn't make sense to me
bro that whole video
is so atrocious she's laughing she's
laughing she's laughing she's like she
said that tastes real good
he's even next man
oh my god that's your partner what are
we doing oh she wasn't she didn't have
enough she wanted more
you just got banged
you literally just got banged there's
still not inside you literally she
didn't clean up nothing went straight to
bed
how fam big man thing
how can you let your man go down there
how how how how can you let him do it
if you love someone even if you like
someone a little bit yeah yeah you would
how could you possibly let them do that
like imagine going out and cheating
you'll go and do an anal and then just
coming home not washing your dick in
your girl
it sucks me off and she's like tastes so
good
i i i promise you'll cry yeah i'd go
flaccid
baby stop
babies
baby stop i'm so i can't i need to tell
you something
she'll bite your ticket
bite your [ __ ] dick i've got a doodoo
dick
baby i'm sorry
[ __ ] it out when you were sleeping i
went to the gas station and nutted in
her ass i piped a ting and knight in her
ass and now i just let you slot the [ __ ]
off my dick oh my god that's a murder
that's a murderer yeah yeah yeah yeah
right
she's on the big big internet telling
the world well i'm just cackling he's
probably just finding out right now yeah
oh yeah it's long bro
it's a long bro imagine that being your
go and you're your ex and you're
literally just you're hearing this
and you know it was you
you know it was you
because you remember the night yeah of
course of course
i'm pulling up to where you are yeah oh
pulling up i'm going to pin i'm going to
play i'm going because you have to
explain yourself you've explained to the
world but explain to me why you thought
i deserved that
explain to me why you thought i deserved
that right what did i do to you i didn't
do it i didn't even think to you
i would be
so perplexed james i'll be so perplexed
it's unbelievable bro
you're you're on soldier boys internet
just laughing
with strangers on a podcast strangers
i'm the part of this joke bro why why
did you do it men always other part of
the jokes man we always are yeah we are
we always are oh that's the thing as
well can you imagine obviously she's not
getting like treated nicely yeah but can
you imagine the role reversal on that if
a man went on a podcast and was laughing
about how he cheated and knighted in
some next girl and came home and his
girlfriend suck it off oh there would be
riots jaime there would be
protests riots protests his handles all
his handles are gone
no one's affiliated with him anymore all
these sponsors are done yeah everything
he's done he's done everything he's done
he's done he's done ah this world is so
backwards sometimes yeah bro she was
laughing up a storm cackling she could
never come on this show and and do that
laugh and get away with it
oh no no no
we're not leaving we're not leaving it
until you belt your husband or belly
apologize
apologize facts we did
because i'm on his side yeah all right
i'm not on your side i don't care what
you did
he didn't do anything
oh bro
that's uh it's not on it's not on it's
really not on it's really not on man
said you explained to the world but
explain to me
[ __ ] it's just not fair
you'd see a growing man quite oh you
you'd see a different
um
i got one trash news and it will jump up
to the ig questions all right but
the caption okay gone
man paralyzed the college student after
ruining his chance with two women
what yes indeed brother
a miami man was sentenced to over four
years in prison after paralyzing a
college student who ruined his chances
to sleep with two women jace christian
williams 23 allegedly attacked the
victim for interrupting him there was a
fight going on between two two random
people when william saw the victim there
witnesses claimed williams approached
owen looper from behind and wrapped his
arms around lewis's on around looper's
body lifted him backwards and slammed
his head first into the ground
trout
texting fam
child testimony revealed in the days
leading up to the crime williams told
the student that he was going to make
sure looper could not use his arms or
legs for five months
specific because he [ __ ] blocked a
threesome
fam just for a second to be fair
miami
if you've patented threesome in miami if
i've planned
two
baddies
by these double checks these happened to
the
tie it up to the gills bro
these club promoter yachts in miami if
i've
snared
two of them not one but two
and we're on my way back to mine and
some [ __ ] has just caught blocked me
i'll probably suplex him as well
i'll probably suplex him as well
what have you done to me
because they've squandered the girls
they've seen this
before it's like [ __ ] i'm not into that
yeah yeah
they're rags
they're [ __ ] someone today i'd be
shake because they were willing they
were both went into [ __ ] you yeah so
they're [ __ ] someone today it's a
wrap i'm suplexing them and then i'll
get someone else to suplex me
[Laughter]
i want to forget i want to forget this
ever happened on our old boy thing fam
you end up in a wheelchair right suplex
man said i want to
when did he say while he's holding him
i'm gonna make sure he doesn't use his
arms and legs for five months why five i
don't know brother that was probably the
first thing i came to say he just
dripped out he just
saw red
and just spoke his mind
bro
can you imagine next man imagine seeing
a bra walk down the road with the two of
the longest things you've seen and he's
just squeezing the cheeks on both sides
and you're like holy [ __ ] and you're in
a fight with something and you just
knock into him and then the things just
scatter ah and he grabs you your arms
are locked in he grabs you here and says
big man
you're not gonna use your arms and legs
for five months scream james i promise
you before he lifts me off the ground i
would [ __ ] scream bro because i'm not
expecting to hear such first of all he's
grabbed me i don't even i can't even
yeah i don't know who he is or what he's
doing
big man you're not gonna use your arms
and legs for five months the five bit is
the scariest thing because you know what
you're doing so [ __ ] specific this
isn't your first suplex
i promise you now
you'll see the biggest yet you've ever
seen because i swear down i'm going to
wrap my legs around the back
no one's picking anyone up no more
supplexes anyway i'm wrapping my legs
around the back of your ankles
my back will be arched
you're not doing it bro
yeah no one could whisper that in my ear
no one could whisper that you feel the
stubble on the back of your neck
big man you ain't using your arms and
legs for five [ __ ] months
fam i will wrap my legs and say why five
my blood will run cold
i know james i know you'd scream i'd
hear you blocks away
help
blocks away
i would be kicking my legs bro
stop oh my goodness
i said bye and no one would stop it from
happening
no one could
it's too quick it's just going to get a
suplex in that's not yeah yeah yeah
a second
jesus christ
yeah that's a wow that is insane wow
suplex thing yes he's experienced very
much so he's [ __ ] experienced very
much it's not a go-to move
[ __ ] you know it's hilarious stuff all
right id questions yeah so guys as per
use you know the vibes ask you a
question of the week and
this question of the week was what's the
worst lie you've ever told
and as per usual guys the responses were
juicy i'm going to hit them hard and
fast and we're going to run through them
let's go so yeah the worst lie you've
ever told this one sweetered me come on
i'm not like other guys
[Laughter]
oh my god
that's funny
[Laughter]
i'm not like that
you can tell fam this is special this
this is you and me we're talking about
baby oh yeah i don't do this for any
girl you know i'm not like other cup
that's true oh the things man will say
to nut
is so real
right that i squirted but really i just
pee to make him feel bad for a bad feel
better for a bad performance oh
wow
that doesn't even sound surprising to me
it doesn't even sound surprising to me
this um
that's peak that's p and he was just
gasped bro gasps kiss all on him
make him feel better for his bad
performance what is that about don't
make me feel anything
especially don't just piss on me
dude that's
disrespectful that's that
imagine imagine seeing that in the group
chat
imagine overlooking her shoulder the
next day she's like this guy thinks he
made me squat i just pat a piss on him i
had to piss on him
listen to me
i'd grab her phone oh rags i'm grabbing
my phone i'm dashing i'm because
there can't be any more evidence of this
there cannot be any more evidence of
this
i'll hack the cloud if i need to
you piss in on man now
anyway
yeah in year seven a girl i knew said
her rich hot boyfriend died in a car
crash right before we could meet him
in year seven
bro that's such a year seven lie
fam when i was in year seven i'd banged
three girls
that i had and they all lived in london
ah what are you saying so
[Laughter]
gilbert gilbert
they all lived there so you couldn't
even appreciate it only a year i only
met them the day that i banged them as
well yeah i went down there for a family
barbecue met a ting banged her and that
was it that was it bro yeah that's not a
virgin ask me silly questions
fam this is
manipulation go on i told my daughter
that when the ice cream van plays music
it means they've run out of ice cream
[Laughter]
nah she wasn't willing to spend a dime
on the door an ice cream man's just
useless
out of stock just roaming the streets
she's gonna grow up one day and realize
your mum my mom is a [ __ ] liar oh
that's a silly thing as well because
kids bro like big man thing if i found
that out like now
i would never forgive myself you
wouldn't be able to i would never
ever forgive myself and your mum has
definitely forgotten about it oh she
didn't give a [ __ ] she doesn't give a
[ __ ]
mom do you remember when you told me
when the ice cream man plays music it
means you ain't got ice cream she's like
oh yeah
silly little lie
i would probably want to rock my mom's
drawer mom i've never had ice cream for
the ice cream man do you understand
i've never had ice cream from the ice
cream man never you've robbed me of
childhood yeah random um quick segue
yeah did your mom do the uh tooth fairy
nah i was going to say this did she [ __ ]
did she [ __ ] tooth fairy because i was
thinking i was listening to the podcast
today and someone was on about the day
they found out that the tooth fairy
wasn't real yeah and for some reason i
was thinking i bet who has mom didn't do
too fairy
tooth fairy so what your teeth just fell
out and that was it
right
oh i read because i i knew from the jump
all these things were folk tale yeah you
know i just knew they were folk tale oh
that's a dread man
that's actually dread i said tooth fairy
numb bro i've been a grown man since
you're seven
you know i mean we didn't dilly dally in
these little child platings
that's dread bro no tooth fairy nothing
no bro wow tooth fairy tooth fairy was
the [ __ ] no my parents always time it
down so i can't your teeth just fell out
and that was it that was it bro
they just told me he's gonna i'm gonna
grow my adult teeth that's it
so what did you do the teacher dash on
the bin what am i meant to do with him
put on your pillow that's some money
that's what you're meant to do with him
there's no i knew from the jump there's
no two phone brother rawr
raw yeah bro
so rod do you think you obviously you
probably wouldn't remember do you think
there was a time where you might have
been like mom two photo and your mom was
like that's not a thing probably
probably but i definitely don't recall
because that would have been like early
primary yeah yeah yeah i don't remember
that's how i've ordered that's her
affordable she whipped us into shape
every man's doing not too far your mom
said that's not a thing that's not a
thing and it definitely is not a thing
under this roof
not in this nigerian household yeah i
don't have spare money to be putting
under pillows
there's bills to pay oh wow oh my
goodness
[ __ ] all that no no toys r us no tooth
fairy no father christmas obviously your
muslim anyway no christmas that that's a
lie though when we were
a lot younger i'd say second but we
still live in crystal palace so
primary school up to probably a seven
we always celebrate christmas or the
christmas period in my house so all the
family and stuff will come over to our
yard because we lived in a living like a
three-floor yard back then so everyone
needs to come to our yard either
christmas day or boxing day or christmas
eve and we just do it up but there's no
santa
yeah that's not me no one's dressing up
there's no santa thing no oh okay never
never no no easter bunny nah easter
bunny come on bro no easter eggs
maybe yes when we were younger when we
were kids kids kids yeah yeah [ __ ] you
now man yeah when we're kids yeah
um
so yeah back to the question the worst
light you've ever told
told this girl i had a car accident so i
couldn't remember who she was i didn't
even like her
[ __ ] it out jesus someone are liars
told parents i'm doing a placement year
when i actually had dropped out of uni
oh i bet bear people have told that like
i don't know how to what end though sure
one night when that year runs out wha
why go on i can't believe as i've like
got older and like met more people i
can't believe the amount of people that
just drop out of uni just i didn't have
that level of chest
to do what i could never drop out of uni
james
my parents will slap me back straight in
there
i could never just return home
in the middle of the year
with bags packed like mom noonie's not
finished it's not for me i decided to
drop out swear
that's cool because where's the money
where are you bringing in the money bro
you're not living under this right yeah
get a yard then because you want to be
grown you want to do big man [ __ ] you'll
think you're better than than degrees
so prove it oh bro that's chest i could
never ever ever bring that to my parents
table oh family if i dropped out you
need to tell i'm doing a podcast
yeah
yeah
they'd burn this room yeah
they'd burn this room and break my
laptop
and they'd literally think i've joined
the cult
literally there was a pro they'd sit me
down and say who who are the friends
you're hanging out with because they
will need to know where i'm getting this
influence from
you know
because they know it's not the real food
they brought up
my mum would honestly think she'd failed
me if i came home in the middle of the
year especially it was like first year
if i'd come home or like to be fair mom
i think i'm just going to start a
podcast
what is that yeah
someone's jaw's getting wrong well me
and fiona are going to sit in the room
and we're just going to chat we're just
going to chat and then we're going to
see what's going on i heard people make
money from it
[ __ ] fam yeah she would have she would
take one pivot step back oh ready to
rock
rock sense
all right back to it
my husband my husband jokes that my guy
best friend is my secret boyfriend
he's oblivious that the joke is secretly
a fact
oh my god
oh my god
that's tough man
girl said that i was allergic to that i
was allergic to semen so i wouldn't give
him head
[ __ ] off i should [ __ ] off yes just [ __ ]
off how about i just don't know
compromise i just woke night in there a
lie meet me halfway oh [ __ ] sake ah
you'll like this one
i pretended to be deaf to avoid people
on the streets asking for donations
fam that was you you didn't even pretend
you just looked through them i looked
through them i continued with my day
brother it was the funniest thing i've
ever seen the most disrespectful thing
you can do another human being
is allow them to put a leaflet
into your chest you look them in your
their eyes but you let them know you
don't see them
you don't even acknowledge the paper
that's touching you fat you just let it
fold into your chest and let the hand
just like bounce off and you just walk
through them it was i couldn't believe
the disrespect you had at uni it was
wild bro i didn't have time you didn't
see them as human beings i didn't have
time for them
i just didn't
i genuinely just didn't i couldn't care
less they were our peers as well well
there were some people on the same
course
oh [ __ ] is what it is
ah jokes told her i was six foot three
but i had a severe i had severe knee
issues so i had to get them removed so
now i'm 5'7
bro can you imagine having to tell that
lie
big man i'm 5'7 but it's not my fault
it's not my fault this is not my
original height i was six three but what
happened was right
ma i was too tall my limbs weren't
limping and i had to get my knees
removed
he ain't got no knees
bro so i'm walking like this now but i'm
five foot seven but that's not five
seven i'm actually six three actually
six so treat me as such
look up yeah yeah look up to my like i'm
the king because that is what i am yeah
i am six threes to treat me like that
wow she'd laugh in my face
not a lie just never told her
kissing a vegan after eating a double
cheeseburger that [ __ ] was delicious
[Laughter]
i told my stepdad that the baby my mom
is having isn't his
do you know that that's a lie you know
that would do to man
do you know what that would do to man
terry it's not yours
she told me or i heard a chatting to her
sister it's not yours
you'd believe it
if my stepson told me that i'm believing
him
but how do you even confront the misses
about that
fam i don't know
[ __ ] bro i literally do not know [ __ ]
that's um that's tough
um next one
i spit below one i was 16.
girl came over to give me some knob
she smelled like cat pee so after she
was done i told her she was going to be
late for work i didn't even know if she
had work that day i just didn't have the
heart to tell her to continue because
she smelt
yuck bro continue what
giving him top
so she came and smelled that piss
he put his dick in her mouth and then
continued to smell the piss
and was like you know what enough you're
going to be late for what you're going
to be late for
my mom said he didn't even know she had
to work
stop stop you're going to be
piss you know but you just thought he
could ride through it
hardik makes you do crazy things no it
does hard dick makes you do crazy
actually does
and hardcore will justify it to you like
if she's just walking around smelling
like cat piss she must be a freak
yeah she must be she must let you do any
and everything to her she's up for it
all
she's just walking around someone like
piss you shouldn't give a [ __ ] she
literally doesn't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it out
oh my days buried a girl's passport on
holiday then helped her look for it
what
and then what
just left her
there was no continuation what was the
motive
these passport things bro don't
don't you dare [ __ ] with my passport i
don't understand i don't understand
why is my passport not on my apple watch
fax
why is it not in my wallet yeah i don't
this passport thing can't continue to
run yeah it needs to be a an electronic
team yeah we live in the future now
this book you want me to hold a book
forever i've lost it three times bro
it's so stressful buried the passport
you know and then helped her look
awesome yeah wow i told my ex he was the
biggest i'd ever been with but he knew i
was lying almost immediately oh
wow
this is the biggest i've ever had shut
the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up your dirty little lying
mouth up
because i know i'm average
i know i'm not a [ __ ] idiot i know
i'm not hung like that baby yeah i know
you've been
she was lying immediately
i just don't understand why and how
those kind of conversations come up like
i would never say to my girl or girl i'm
seeing a girl i'm [ __ ] baby is my
dick big for you like what
why some certain i need that though
certain man literally need that
i don't know why they need it but people
have their reasons does man need it they
need that that
positive affirmation like tell me i'm
that guy because a lot of men just
aren't that guy yeah at any other point
in their life yeah so when i'm piping
you
like i need to hear it
that
right i told my five-year-old niece i'd
been on vacation when they let me out
the psych ward
oh jesus christ
my dad died in a car crash and it's why
i don't drive because he had laughed at
me for not driving
her face would have dropped oh family it
would have
the whole thing would have spiraled what
do you drive i don't i don't rob big man
you don't even drive [ __ ] boy you don't
drive yeah my [ __ ] dad died in the
car accident that's why i don't drive
you insensitive little prick
that's my dad died in a [ __ ] car all
i could be able to do
is it oh yeah it is actually
that's why i don't drive because i'm
terrified of it
but yeah hahaha
let's all laugh a little orphan boy
this will laugh it up it was dead dad
ah
meanwhile he's just lying he's just
dad's yard
that's literally at yards literally at
your car parked in a car park
oh my days [ __ ] it out
told my colleagues i cut my face on a
broken jar actually my mum beat the [ __ ]
out of me
colleagues
not even schoolmates colleagues
man was at work
wow
this one
is why
mandem
are holding up guns in schools oh my god
[ __ ] myself at school when i wa oh sorry
[ __ ] myself at school when i was a kid
and i blamed it on the quiet kid next to
me he was bullied for a whole year
nah fam that kid will either jump or
shoot
one of the two
bro i was bullied he was bullied for a
whole year he didn't do anything he was
an innocent bias because i'm a quiet man
don't take my quietness for for fullness
bro
i remember this is how bad and that
is we went on a school trip once to some
i don't even know what it was
all i know is they had there was like
some activity center yeah and they had
this weird [ __ ] swamp
and you had to like zipline over it okay
would you like rope swings yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
fam
on the letter that went out about the
school trip no one said bring spare gums
spare trainers nothing okay no one said
nothing about it okay okay so these
times yeah i'm doing some rope swing
team yeah you're falling into the things
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i didn't think about the
bus ride home yeah fam the whole time
i stink now yeah i [ __ ] stink did
everyone have a change of clothes yes
everyone else knew the drill everyone
got showered and changed bro i still had
to wear my doodoo clips
so we got back on the coach home it's
like a 40 minute drive home and when i
say i was stinking up the bus bro
and every every single person on the bus
was like james man
you [ __ ] stink bro i'd [ __ ] close
up your right shoulder the back of the
bus just just swinging and shaking let's
stop please please
i couldn't i could never see the back
i'd run to the front i let homeboy drop
me off 20 minutes from my house
to make it stop
just to make it you're not walking on
roads full of mud squelching on road for
20 minutes
just to stop the the brutality that was
going on in that box bro kids are evil
as a collective
[ __ ] evil everyone was louder than
the last
and man had that for a year a year
brother didn't even stink
it wasn't him yeah
nah
this is why
kids boys are the worst the worst
my friend told me she was pregnant with
twins so they would jump on her stomach
because she was scared of abortions she
wasn't even pregnant
family what exactly
my friend told someone she was pregnant
with twins so they would jump on her
stomach because she was scared of
abortions she wasn't even pregnant
where's the means to an end
what
what on earth was she thinking
she just wanted someone jumping on her
stomach she wanted pain yeah yeah yeah
and attention together
attention is the word pain sympathy and
attention all come on wrapped in one
i'm pregnant and i'm terrified to get an
abortion
jump on my tummy now
i couldn't be a part of that you a girl
couldn't come up to me and tell me to
jump on a stomach who got jumped on it
who jumped on it exactly
so you're a little killer now that's
what you are yeah i'll jump
who who's that one i'll jump
oh my goodness you're a little killer
christ [ __ ]
i got two more i bet told work i
told work i got mugged when they
actually
hold on
told work i got mugged when i was
actually at a gangbang they gave me a
few days off with trauma
you didn't go into work because you were
at a gang bang
fam was there not a different gang bang
on a weekend or saturn
[ __ ] man wow they gave me a few days off
of trauma she recovered she definitely
recovered because
yeah that [ __ ] was drawn yeah i was
gonna say that [ __ ] had been banged
in
last one
my mum found hickeys on my neck i told
her it was a reaction from ibuprofen she
forced me to get several blood tests
[Laughter]
that's funny bro
that's actually funny
oh my days
oh [ __ ] me that was hilarious oh yeah
that's it for this week guys that was it
guys um thank you so much for joining us
make sure you head on over to patreon to
join us for episode 200. um it's going
to be lavish guys um and as always love
love love
[Music]